so I'm Bobby and I'm gonna talk to you
today about compacting the uncompact
able than providing memory compaction
for C and C++ programs and I want to
start out today by by starting with a
story and this story is the impossible
dreams there's an older version of this
story that stars Don Quixote the Man of
La Mancha and in this this older version
of the story he wants either reconquer
or reintroduced chivalry to all of Spain
now today though the version we're going
to talk about features the Malek of La
Mancha and rather than reality or
reconquer all of Spain we want to
allocate all of Spain so in this story
here we have Spain and when our hero
gets Malek requests he looks around on a
map and they find you know three chunks
of Spain and and hands them back to
whoever requested it and you know at the
beginning of the story this this this
process is pretty easy we can just sort
of march on down the map here allocating
the next free chunk we find however over
time some of these old areas that we had
allocated are no longer needed and our
freed and so so so eventually we end up
in a situation where we have little
chunks of free space spread throughout
the map here and we get a new request we
get a new large allocation request and
unfortunately we don't have enough free
space here
that's contiguous that's near each other
to serve this request what our hero
really wants to do is to somehow be able
to to move these existing requests
together to which which consequently
will move all of our free space together
so that we can serve this request
unfortunately this is this is not that
simple if you if you imagine in the real
world if you purchase some land to build
a house you build a house there you you
start raising a family in this house and
then someone shows up and tells you that
actually your land is is four miles to
the left you're gonna feel very angry
and sad and that's that's basically what
a segfault feels like to a program so we
can't we can't do this and this problem
that we're talking about is memory
fragmentation
and what memory fragmentation is is when
a program requires much more memory from
the operating system than the some of
the live objects that you're working on
when this ratio is much greater than one
and there's actually strong theoretical
bounds dating all the way back to 1977
with Robson that show that fragmentation
in programs like in programs written in
languages like C and C++ with non-moving
alligators that this fragmentation can
be over an order of magnitude can be up
to 13 X and it's related to the
logarithmic ly to the the size of the
largest size class over the smallest
size class and when we talked about
moving things together what this is is
memory compaction and what this would
let us do is is move our live objects
together to give the rest of that memory
back to the operating system so that the
operating system could use it for other
programs or or better purposes in the
original version of this story Don
Quixote tilts at windmills right he
fights fights imaginary enemies but
unfortunately one of the other
differences in our modern story is we
have we have some real enemies or foes
this is Ken Thompson and Dennis Ritchie
who have invented the C programming
language which is sort of the root of
our the root of our woes here but it's
not only the C programming language
there's there's languages built on top
of this C++ that feature manual memory
management and and more recently there
are languages like rust and Swift that
automate some of this memory management
but don't have moving memory alligators
that that have chosen to under the hood
manually manage memory and Chris Lautner
is the developer who created LLVM and
then created the Swift programming
language and and talked about why a
modern programming language created in
the last few years would choose to
forego using a garbage collector who
would choose to forego some technology
that might help us here and he has a
bunch of great points but but one of the
big ones is that in order for garbage
collectors to run efficiently and serve
your allocation requests efficiently
they require three to four X more memory
than other solutions so so you you're
required with a garbage collector to
have a bunch of free space
sitting around and this is this is at
odds with with what a lot of people want
both on mobile devices as well as on the
server and on desktops which is
minimizing memory usage and Chris
actually quoted my adviser and
collaborator on this work Emery had some
some work he had done that that
quantifies these these performance
impacts and on top of these programming
languages we have lots and lots of
software in use today that's written in
them right our databases are written in
C and C++ our web browsers are
spreadsheets lots of applications that
we interact with every day potentially
suffer from these problems and don't
have a solution to fragmentation but
it's not only applications written in C
and C++ there are other programming
languages like Ruby and Python here that
actually the interpreters that people
use for these languages every day are
are themselves C programs and under the
hood if you ask for large objects it
will call malloc so on the other side of
the fence here we have we have some
languages that that are able to address
this problem right we're not the first
people to to wonder about fragmentation
or hope to provide compaction and these
languages have solved this with garbage
collection because they have a garbage
collector they're able to move objects
closer together and to understand why we
can't just adapt existing solutions for
our C and C++ programs let's look at
what compaction looks like under a
garbage collected language so we have
three things going on here we have
operating system pages we have live
objects that are smaller than the
operating system page and we have
references we have pointers between
objects and what the garbage culture is
going to do what the runtime is going to
do here is it's going to want to to move
these objects closer together to free up
one of these pages to give it back to
the operating system and every time our
runtime moves an object the key thing
here is that it has to update every
single reference every single pointer
that points to that object to make sure
that there are no mem
safety errors right and once it's done
this we're left with a free page that we
can return back to the operating system
so back in c and c++ land things are a
little bit different rather than this
sort of strong runtime that java and you
know dotnet provide instead we compile C
and C++ programs down to machine code
and often even we strip any sort of
symbol information or debug symbols from
the binary before sending it out and
running it in production right this is
just extra bytes that that we don't want
to ship across the wire sometimes and so
when we run these programs the the sort
of real problem here is that we can't
distinguish what's a pointer from what's
application data and so so let's sort of
look at what this means imagine we have
an allocation that lives at address that
you know this address starting with with
dead and we want to move it to this
other address at beef now if we scan
through an applications heap and we find
four bytes that look like this pointer
we actually you know from from the
memory alligators perspective we can't
really tell if this is a pointer or if
this is just application data right this
may just be somebody's somebody's
password somebody's favorite phrase or
or you know some some numerical data
that just happens to look like a pointer
we can't precisely say yes or no whether
this is a pointer and if we can't even
identify what a what is a pointer we
can't safely update it but lest let's do
you think like okay maybe we can just
solve this with some additional
additional work in the compiler by you
know maybe passing more type information
around or or alternatively maybe if we
just don't strip debug symbols we can we
can solve this in a pretty good way it's
it's unfortunately not not to be this is
some code I pulled off of Stack Overflow
and one of the things about scene C++
developers is they they really like
being efficient right C and C++
developers myself included
of being efficient and so this developer
has realized that if you look at the
spec for the language it says that any
requests that come back any pointers you
get back from Malick are at least eight
byte aligned and what this means is that
the lowest three bits of any pointers
you get from Malick are always going to
be zero well if they're always going to
be zero maybe we can just use those to
store some flags imagine we have some
boolean Flags if we can store them in
the pointer we can use a C Union type to
sort of nicely manage this and then just
mask out those bits before we actually
want to use the pointer and this saves
whole bytes right whole bytes on every
single object that we want to manage
this way and this this code like lives
in the real world there's lots of lots
of examples like this so this means that
if we're we're trying to look through
the heap and find pointers we can't even
necessarily find all of the pointers
right they may not look like pointers
until they're actually immediately about
to be used and sitting in a register
somewhere so so this is sort of the
environment that a memory allocator has
to has to live in and has to work in if
it wants to provide compaction and
that's why existing techniques don't
really apply here which brings us to
mesh mesh is our memory allocator for C
and C++ are drop-in replacement for
malloc that is able to provide
compaction without having to do any
relocation without having to identify or
move any pointers mesh works without
having any code chain without requiring
any code changes so we don't require you
to remove those pesky Union types it
doesn't even require a recompilation you
just have to link against Lib mesh or
even just LD preload the mesh and go and
your program will use our versions of
malloc and free and the other related
memory allocation functions to provide
provide compaction so we ran a web
benchmark in Firefox we ran speedometer
it's a well-known web benchmark I think
it runs a lot of sample to-do list
applications in a row a bunch of times
to test how fast the browser is with Dom
manipulation and JavaScript and a mix of
all of that and we saw that over the
course of this benchmark
when Firefox used Live Mesh there's an
on average a 17% heap size reduction and
the the score reported by speedometer at
the end of this was within 1% of Firefox
with its default allocator Redis is an
in-memory key-value datastore and one of
the ways that people can use Redis is as
an LRU cache so you can tell Redis hey I
want you to store objects in a cache
like manner and but use that most you
know X number of megabytes of memory and
if I go to insert more objects that
would overflow this size kick out some
old objects and so people reported to
the Redis github you know open up github
issues and said hey when we do this we
see actually a lot of memory
fragmentation Redis developers were able
to pull this down into a reproducible
test case and they actually wrote their
own application specific defragmentation
routine that depends on the fact you
know essentially read us with some to a
first approximation is a very large hash
map behind a socket and they take
advantage of the fact that this is sort
of a very specific he play out to to
code up a defragmentation routine that
works with the default memory allocator
and is able to recover from compaction
in this case on this graph here the blue
line at the top is what the memory usage
of Redis over time looks like under this
test case without defragmentation
there's a dotted red line in the middle
here which is what the heap usage over
time looks like with Redis
defragmentation routine and green at the
bottom is mesh so we're able to recover
as much memory as this
application-specific defragmentation
routine in a completely generic way but
not only that we're able to do it much
much faster so we're able to do it with
5 X less cycles spent performing
compaction which is great because Redis
is single threaded so anytime it's spent
doing compaction it's time that it's
bent not serving allocation or sorry not
serving requests
so in order to to provide this this
compaction for C and C++ there were
three challenges we had to solve the
first is we had to find a mechanism to
compact the heap together to Kent to
compact pages in the heap together that
didn't require updating pointers next is
that we had to make sure that if we're
experiencing fragmentation that we could
always apply this mechanism to recover
from that fragmentation and finally the
the last the last key piece here is
searching we had to we had to have some
way to efficiently find pages in the
heap that we could compact together that
were eligible for this technique and I'm
doing a little bit of genre mixing here
but these three pieces combined together
give us this ability to perform what we
call meshing which is compaction without
virtual relocation and so let's dig into
the mechanism here first we see that
pages are measurable when two things
hold the first is that they these pages
have objects of the same size class we
don't consider meshing meshing pages in
the heap together if they hold objects
of different sizes and and we'll talk
about why that's not a problem in a few
minutes but the second constraint here
is that all of the live objects across
these two pages have to have
non-overlapping offsets there can't be
any duplicate offsets if you count the
object from the start of the page and
these two pages meet those requirements
so let's look at let's look at what
happens when we when we have candidate
pages here the first thing to think
about is that there's kind of two views
of memory right there's virtual memory
which is the heap from the perspective
of a program and then there's physical
memory which is you know the fact that
somewhere in your computer in some RAM
chips these bits and bytes live right
and when we talk about not being able to
change pointers or move things we're
really talking about things from the
virtual memory perspective from the
applications perspective so the first
thing we do to provide compaction is we
mark one of these pages as read-only
this prevents concurrent rights to
objects while we're performing meshing
the next is that we we copy objects from
one physical page to the other while
maintaining the object offsets from the
start of the page so if we have you know
some objects on the left and we have
some objects on the right because none
of these object offsets overlap we can
sort of mesh them together right and and
maintain maintain their relative
positions here next we can update the
processes we update the processes page
tables to point both of these virtual
pages at the same physical page and
we're able to do this with a call to the
M map with an M map system call and and
in particular we're able to have this
sort of fine-grained control over page
tables because our heap is backed by an
in-memory temporary file that's mapped
into the processes address space with
the map shared flag and that gives us
this this mechanism to sort of directly
poke at the page tables and and you know
once this has happened we can mark this
this source page that we copied objects
off of at the virtual layer we can mark
this readwrite again and any concurrent
writers can now sort of proceed on
proceed on their way and we're left with
a free page that we can give back to the
operating system here that is no longer
reference from the virtual address of
our of our program and the the operating
system now is free to use this for a
different program but it can even give
us back this physical page in the future
for use in a different size class and
and again just to highlight because
we've maintained these object offsets no
virtual addresses of these objects were
changed and so we didn't have to even
identify pointers in the processes heap
so this is great we now have a mechanism
to do this compaction but it's somewhat
easy to imagine a worst case scenario
imagine you have a number of pages
they're all very low occupancy they all
only have a single object on them but
that object is on the first is in the
first object offset right they're all
sort of conflicting and they don't meet
our
for meshing and instead of two objects
you might have many many many of these
sorry instead of two pages you might
have many of these pages and this isn't
just sort of you know a fun to think
about hypothetical problem it's
something that can actually occur with
standard allocators so if you call
meshed a number of times in a row with
the same size request imagine you're
asking for 256 byte objects you will
often get back a number of contiguous
allocation a number of contiguous
pointers in memory and to avoid this
worst case scenario mesh uses
randomization to ensure that we actually
don't do this we don't give out
consecutive addresses in memory but we
spread allocations across the page
uniformly and we were able to write a
very simple ruby program I think it's
about 30 or 40 lines it does a bunch of
you know nice clean functional
programming type operations maps and
exhibits fragmentation in exactly this
way and we built mesh in sort of two
configurations to test this out we built
it in the normal way and then we also
built it with randomization disabled and
when randomization was disabled we
weren't able to recover any memory but
with randomization enabled we were able
to recover about you know 20 percent or
so of the heap size so so randomization
is really works and is necessary in this
case which brings us to sort of how do
we do this how do we sort of efficiently
add randomization to our allocator
previous approaches use something called
random probing in random probing when
you call malloc
you have this sort of pseudo code here
where there's a wild true loop you
generate a random offset and you just
check to see is the is the slot sort of
at this offset free if so give back a
pointer give back a pointer for that
position otherwise you know try again
you know go to the top of the while loop
and eventually you will find you'll find
a free spot too to return diehard a
memory allocator to sort of
probabilistically let programs continue
executing in the face of memory or
exactly this this is this is how diehard
did randomized allocation and this while
loop in your memory allocator may sound
sort of a little it may sound suspicious
but actually in expectation as long as
occupancy is low on these pages we
expect to only go through this loop once
twice maybe three times as long as we
keep page occupancy low and this is what
diehard did diehard made sure that once
a page was you know cross some threshold
of fullness
we started allocating out of new pages
this is directly at odds with what we're
trying to do today right with this
allocator which is minimize heap usage
so we needed a different approach and
what we developed was something called
the shuffle vector shelf electors
provide this fast randomized allocation
along with full page utilization so
shuffle vectors work like this we we
find a candidate page that we want to
allocate out of and we pull those
offsets down into a thread-local array
and once we have them in the
thread-local array we call shuffle and
this performs the the fishery eights
shuffle to randomize the order of items
in this list quickly when we request the
mallet comes in we're able to basically
just pull the first item off this list
do some very simple math to turn it back
to a pointer and give it back to the
program this is almost as fast as an
alligator can get when a program fries
fries this address in the future we just
do the inverse of that math to get an
offset from the pointer stick it on the
front of this list and call shuffle one
this is a single iteration of the
fishery each shuffle that just randomly
swaps what we've added with an item in
the list and this ensures that if we end
up in low occupancy situations we can
always apply with high probability we
can always apply this meshing technique
to recover from fragmentation so we have
two pieces of the puzzle and the last
one is how we find pages to mesh state
it a little bit more formally what we
want to do is we want to find a meshing
we want to find a list of
that subpages to mesh that releases the
maximum number of pages at a given point
in time and this is going to run in the
free slow path every so often when you
call free we're going to do this you
could imagine this running in a separate
thread but that would require some
amount of application specific
integration and it's going to run at
most once every hundred milliseconds so
one of think the best way to sort of
conceptualize this problem here is as a
graph problem and this is this is sort
of a visualization of this graph in this
graph we have pages in the heap and then
we have edges between pages if there's a
meshing relationship and the great thing
about graphs is that they're very well
studied objects right and we can we can
think about applying existing techniques
here so one existing algorithm that
would solve this problem exactly for us
it's called min click cover a clique is
a set of strongly connected nodes where
they all have edges between them and
I've highlighted the min Klee cover
solution here for all cliques of size
greater than one so we could each one of
these independent sets of nodes we could
mesh together and free the maximum
amount of amount of pages back to the
operating system the the small problem
here is that mini cover is MP complete
it is computationally very hard in a
rigorous sense but actually the fact
that we're using randomization in our
allocator comes back to help us
randomization ensures that we can get
away with solving a much simpler problem
called matching and the details of why
we can solve the simpler problem are in
an academic paper that we wrote on this
that I'd be happy to talk to you about
afterwards so so this is great we can
apply a an existing algorithm
potentially that is in NP the problem is
that the last remaining problem here is
that if we wanted to use an existing
version
the match match of matching the matching
algorithm we would have to explicitly
build this graph in memory we would have
to explicitly find all of these edges in
memory before we could run the algorithm
and building this graph would require
time but more importantly it would
require space right we would have to
allocate space to store this graph and
it turns out that if you wanted to
allocate space to store this graph it
would vastly exceed the amount of memory
that we would get back from freeing from
the result of this algorithm so so we
needed something else and we came up
with an algorithm called split measure
and split measure is an approximation
algorithm that approximates matching
without having to actually build this
graph in memory and the function
signature looks like this it takes a set
of partially full pages and it returns
pairs of pages to mesh and the way it
works the way it works is has following
Li sort of take that input we split it
into two lists two sort of arbitrary
lists and then we iterate comparing a
sub I to B sub I and then comparing the
item on the left to the item on the
right and we just check to see is there
an edge there are these pages measurable
and we can do this efficiently with we
have bitmaps that store information on
occupancy for pages and we can use CPU
intrinsic to do this quite fast when we
get to the bottom of this list we
actually just you know return to the top
increment the offset on the right by one
and continue marching down and the key
thing here is that we do this a fixed
number of times we do this incrementing
of b sub i on the right fixed number of
times that is independent of the input
which means which means great things to
run time that we'll talk about in a
second but if we find a pair of pages
that have a measuring relationship that
we can can pack together to free space
we remove it from the list we stick it
off to the side to return later and then
we just continue on and we show that
actually split master runs in linear
time with respect to the input with
respect to the size of the
keep and the running time is also sort
of dependent on the global probability
global probability of strands meshing so
so it's it's also proportional to sort
of how fragmented the heap is but the
really great thing here is that not only
does this run quickly but we have very
strong bounds on how good of a match
that we find and and we show that this
is actually an arbitrarily close to 1/2
approximation with high probability
which has a lot of hedging words but
they're all very precise words
essentially means that that we make sure
that we find a solution that is at least
half as good as the optimal solution
every time we run this algorithm and
that's why we're able to sort of do so
well with a general technique compared
to even application specific techniques
that encode a bunch of information about
sort of you know the precise he play out
and types of things and we do this
efficiently we do this with much less
CPU time spent compared to in this
example Redis is case the the graph on
the left here shows insert time during
this during this test case during this
LRU test case one of the worries that
that we and and reviewers had was that
adding randomization to our allocator
would somehow decrease locality and slow
things down on average either because
you know finding random numbers in the
allocation path is is more expensive
than not using randomization but you
know maybe there's some locality
question here as well but it turns out
to not be the case there's almost
there's a very very very small impact on
insert time and Redis caused by our
allocator and then you know again just
to recap here we're able to save
significant space on on applications
like Firefox that have spent years
trying to sort of decrease their heap
usage over time right Firefox was I
think there was like a several year
project to to reduce the heap size there
and and finally I think maybe I'm
excited about all of this but maybe most
excite
we can provide compaction for four
dynamic languages like Ruby and
JavaScript for free without having to
touch your change the existing garbage
collector here just by using a different
memory allocator under the hood which is
which is quite neat and so you can find
out more at libya org this links to our
github page it's open source you can
download it and play with it and it also
links to our academic paper from there
so thank you very much yeah we have some
time so I would be happy to take
questions I saw that hand first
so so the question is is that the
observation is that we're sort of
compacting and freeing physical pages
but not virtual pages and and are we
leaking those virtual pages and what's
the impact of that did I state that yeah
yeah so I think the the the interesting
limits here are that Linux today we ran
this mostly under Linux but it also runs
on Mac OS under Linux there's a maximum
amount of memory that the kernel will
allow to store page tables and if you
have a very fragmented program and you
don't adjust the defaults this can be
quite low and you can hit this and we
sort of detect that and you know make
sure to not not do bad things there but
what we also do is once you've imagined
you've compacted several pages together
once you free all of the objects on
those pages we reset the mappings to the
identity mappings between virtual and
physical pages so that in the future
those work kind of as you would expect I
saw the black shirt back there issues
like so the question is this mesh have
any effect on issues like cache
coherency I think the answer is no but I
also am NOT deeply intimately familiar
with cache coherency so maybe we talk
after this butBut I think the answer is
no because of the marking pages as
read-only before we perform this
physical page movement so we ensure sort
of in a somewhat pessimistic way that we
never see writes to these objects while
we're moving them around physically
until they're already moved and then we
we mark them as read write again thanks
uh maybe one other thing there is I
believe that it depends on whether
caches are like physically
or virtually tagged and because we're
moving things around physically and most
it let's talk afterwards but I think
we're good
yes yeah yeah so so the question is is
why would doing mesh off thread require
application coordination and the answer
is that C and C++ programs make
assumptions that when the main thread
runs it is the only thread running and
if your library starts up a thread
before main runs you know you can do
initialization of libraries before main
runs things blow up Firefox for example
does some sandboxing of itself and if
there are other and sandboxing on linux
works in in weird and terrible ways and
that it works sort of threads
specifically so firefox is unable to
successfully sandbox itself if there are
other threads running because what it
wants to do is sandbox the main thread
and then after it's in that sandbox for
that thread spawn other threads which
end up in the same sandbox so it's it's
things like that just just sort of
general assumptions that these programs
make that that mean we have to do sort
of pessimistic things like not sort of
threads on her own can the question is
can we lazily spawn a background thread
i roughly feel like i tried this and it
didn't work out well but i don't
remember the specifics that was a long
time ago and I think in anger we just
said well we'll just do it in the free
slow path and it happens rarely enough
that it's it's not a not a large concern
yes uh-huh
yep
so the question is what happens if
another thread tries to write to this
page that we've just marked read-only
and the answer there is that we install
a seg fault handler it triggers a
segmentation fault or it triggers a
signal the operating system slash CPU
pause it at that instruction our handler
runs and then our Handler through very
careful coding waits until this meshing
operation is done before returning from
the handler and there's a way to return
from a seg fault Angela that says
actually things are fine just try that
exact instruction again and when it
tries that instruction again after this
has been completed and after that page
is read right everything works as normal
so the question is what if the
application is a seg fault handler and
and the answer is that we we will nest
seg fault handlers so we will we check
we try to check very specifically to say
is this seg fault actually because this
page is read-only due to an ongoing
meshing operation and if not then we
either crash the application or call the
application seg fault handler yep yes
so the question is what could operating
system do to make this building to make
building this simpler I think one of the
biggest things is some bulk way to
update page tables like what we do right
now is every single pair of pages to
mesh we have to do this dance of of
updating that and that's a significant
cost because every time we update these
page tables we have to like this the
operating system under the hood does
like a TLB flush which is a synchronous
operation across all processors so if we
had some bulk way to say you know we
have the results of this split measure
algorithm we know we want to mesh all of
these if we could mark everything as
read-only at once update all the page
tables at once and then you know
unmarked things at once I think that
would significantly speed things up yes
why is it Firefox using it that's a
that's a good question we I believe were
we had some email discussions with them
it's a relatively new allocator and I
I'm I'm not sure in particular you know
I'm not I don't work for Mozilla and in
general just speaking speaking in
general like it's it's nice to continue
to use things that you deeply and
intimately are familiar with I would
love to talk more with people from
Mozilla about what we could do to to
sort of prove this out and and see if if
we could run Firefox with it yes yes
yep so the question is what if what if
the application is doing some of its own
stuff with virtual memory allocation do
you have an example
got it
right so so to summarize like sometimes
game engines in particular do things
like create circular ring buffers so
that in overflow on one side just sees
the beginning of the array or something
like that all of that is is is fine I
understand is that applications that do
things like that will allocate their own
memory with em map like in general you
you don't allocate something through
malloc and then futz with the yeah yeah
we've replaced malloc and the malloc
related calls and any direct calls to em
map an application is free to continue
doing okay back there
so so I think the question is like
can-can allocators that already do
compaction use this technique as an
alternative approach to
got it so our are moving garbage
collectors just doing extra work if we
can already do compaction this way and I
think the answer is no because garbage
collectors by necessity have to walk the
graph of the heap to find out if objects
are live and so essentially because they
already have to sort of walk over either
the entire heap or you know if it's a
generational collector the young gen
because they already have to do this
they can they can sort of relatively
cheaply you know add in the the moving
and updating parts to that that's it's
my rough understanding okay it's time
thank you all again
[Applause]